[Música]
como un dragón dormido las colinas de la
isla de Palma continúan resoplando y
resoplando cubierto de ceniza pero muy
activo el impactante paisaje atrae a
visitantes de todo el mundo como un imán
bastante espectacular Es realmente bueno
de ver un ambiente sereno y de belleza
natural deja de atrás por la erupción
volcánica más devastadora de Europa en
casi un siglo a finales de 2021 la lava
fluyó por la cresta de Cumbre vieja como
un río Al rojo vivo la erupción duró 85
días la más larga en la historia del
archipiélago las casas las tiendas y las
escuelas fueron arrasadas enteras pero
hoy en día los turistas pueden visitar
sitios restringidos en visitas guiadas
caminando por un bosque de Pinos
alfombrado con ceniza negra
a medida que nos acercamos puedes
comenzar a buscar estas bombas
volcánicas otra cosa aquí es señalar que
los pinos se oscurecen aquí se debe a la
falta de clorofila
y no son solo los excursionistas que
sean multiplicados desde la erupción ha
aumentado el número de cruceros que
hacen escala aquí así como el número de
vuelos directos desde España peninsular
y otros lugares una agradable sorpresa
para los negocios en esta Isla canaria
antes menos conocida el volcán haya
ayudado a la palma a posicionarse a que
muchos antes del volcán La Palma la
confundían con Las Palmas de Gran
canaria o con palma de mallorca un
impulso al turismo y a la economía local
es lo que la isla necesita
desesperadamente más de un año después
de que cesó la erupción grandes
extensiones de tierra permanecen
enterradas en cenizas volcánicas la
agricultura ha sido devastada y barrios
como este siguen acordonados y desiertos
debido a los altos niveles de gas tóxico
en el que los hacen inseguros para vivir